and so Trump comes in he goes huh I see
everybody around me is lying about 30%
of the time and it seems to be effective
I'll ramp that up to 70 see what happens
hey hey and welcome this is the Ben
Shapiro shows Sundays special we have as
our special guest this Sunday Scott
Adams he is the creator of Dilbert and
also the author of win big lay so you
can go check that out we will get into
his book and his theory that President
Trump is in fact a master communicator
in one second first we're gonna talk
about the fact that you are gonna die so
here's the deal you're gonna plotz get
used to it feel that in your marrow
right down in the bones and now go get
some life insurance because if you
really understand that you're gonna die
then you know you need life insurance
because otherwise you are going to leave
your family bereft now a lot of people
don't have life insurance because it's
kind of hard to buy you have to work out
what you need do the research to find
the best quote and hope you don't get
swindled along the way that's not a good
way to shop for anything so policy
genius made the whole process a lot
simpler policy genius compares quotes
from the top life insurance companies to
find the best policy for you it takes a
couple of minutes to get a quote that's
it and if you don't know the first thing
about insurance they've got all the
tools you need to get up to speed
learn the difference between term and
whole life insurance calculate how much
coverage you need and be sure you're
making the right decision in fact over 4
million people have used policy genius
to shop for insurance policy genius
doesn't just make life insurance easy
they also compare disability insurance
and home insurance and auto insurance if
you care about it they can cover it so
whether you know a lot about life
insurance or nothing at all start your
search of policy genius com in just two
minutes you can compare quotes make that
informed decision for you and your
family policy genius is the easy way to
compare and buy life insurance well
Scott thanks so much for stopping by I
really appreciate it so let's start off
with this how did the creator of Dilbert
become the Trump guy totally
accidentally I wrote one blog post in
which I I thought I saw some some skill
in him back in 2015 that people weren't
noticing I thought he had a persuasion
talents that were unusual and I wrote a
blog post called clown genius and it was
hugely viral and I thought well I'll
write one more and that was viral as
well and everything I wrote about Trump
got more traffic than anything else I
was doing which is the same
of every other person right Rob right
the universal experience I thought it
was just me but it's so interesting I
can't stop doing it I'm feel I'm
actually addicted in some way not how
politically did you end up at the point
where the left now considers you a
Trumpkin even though you consider
yourself when you talk about in the book
the fact that you're pretty liberal on a
lot of major issues yeah and the social
stuff and then the big stuff I don't
understand you know look if you ask me
what's the best trade deal with China I
don't know you know I don't know if does
anybody really know but on the little
stuff like you know gay marriage yes you
know should we should we have universal
health care I'd like to see it I just
don't know how to pay for it so I'm sort
of a liberal with an economics degree so
it makes me a hybrid and yet the fact
that you sort of considered Trump to be
an actual good communicator to let
everybody to believe that you are deeply
embedded in the right now and that you
are in fact president Trump's number-one
proponent I call myself a supporter but
I also call myself a supporter of every
sitting president so I was an Obama
supporter primarily I had one issue with
him but I support the president in
general well is it one issue with Obama
so Obama originally said he was going to
let the the weed business in California
alone and in the States alone and then
he got in office and he changed his mind
now that would have been okay with a
reason you know here's my reason I
thought about it here's the new facts
but without a reason one must assume
there's something going on and without a
reason you have to assume he's bought
right now if he'd explained it I would
certainly accept the explanation if it
was anything reasonable but without the
explanation I considered that a removed
from office kind of situation okay so
let's talk about your Trump theory so
you sort of became famous on in Trump
circles obviously you're always famous
before that for Dilbert and everything
else that you do but he became as became
famous in sort of political circles for
taking this peculiar view in 2015 the
president Trump was in fact a
communication genius that he was
actually terrific at this and that
everybody who's out there mocking him
and thinking he's a fool
that we all had it wrong what made you
think that President Trump was a genius
at communication so I've got a
background as a hypnotist I was a
trained hypnotist and
20s and I've been studying all the the
ways of persuasion for decades as part
of my work so to be a good writer I
learned how to add a word of things how
to how to do marketing how to do sales
how to negotiate these are all related
topics and when you look at Trump he's
got he's you know first of all he wrote
a book I'm negotiating so we should sort
of you read it you read it but but even
if you just brand yourself as a
negotiating person it attracts that
knowledge to you over time so in in all
chip in all likelihood he knows more
about negotiating that most people on
the planet because it's an interest and
he doesn't lot but he also had this this
weird experience as a kid so when he was
in church the his family pastor I
believe was norman vincent peale
the the the author who wrote the power
of positive thinking which in a sense is
a persuasion bible for people of those
times and it was about how they use
optimism essentially I'll you know
paraphrase it too much but but it was
having to think your way into a better
situation and we see him modeling that
all the time I don't think it's a
coincidence you know if you sit in that
church with someone who was considered
so influential so persuasive this is
Norman Vincent Peale he was actually
accused of being a hypnotist in his day
he was so persuasive so I think Trump
comes by it honestly and essentially
he's been around it and then he's also
developed it over his career but beyond
that I noticed a lot of specific tag
Beach that you wouldn't notice if you
don't study this stuff so what were some
of the techniques that first jumped out
at you that you think President Trump
was using so the wall let's take the
easiest example a visual persuasion is
the most powerful if you had a concept
let's say you said well there are too
many people coming across the border
alright our crime rate is up 5% or
whatever you're going to say concepts
don't persuade you show a picture of a
wall and people want it or don't want it
you show a picture of a caravan of
people coming and people say that's
immigration now I have a visual image
you'll watch that the President does
visual imagery so consistently compared
to anybody else in the game
just the most visual thinker he
simplifies simplifying is hugely
important politicians want to act like
that are the academic the smart one the
lawyer in the room so they're there
their impulse is to get a little bit
more complicated than the people they're
talking to remember Trump was mocked for
what they say at a fourth or sixth grade
vocabulary or something like that yeah
but if you talk to anybody who's an
expert in this field they'll say well
what's the audience okay he's talking to
the audience in the way that you talk to
people who you know or operating on that
level do you think that when he's in
private he talks like a British
professor or suddenly he sounds like you
know he suddenly sounds like ayaan Hirsi
Ali closed doors well the several weeks
ago I got to meet him so I was a newly
shocked by his mellifluous British
accent yeah the British accent totally
through baby no you seemed exactly the
same person just you know the relaxed
version in the room although I'm not
sure I've I'm not sure you ever yeah I'm
so I guess that that is one of the
questions is how much of this do you
think I mean look he's obviously a guy
who gets his message across in unique
ways and with a unique sort of appeal
how much of this is conscious and how
much of this is just natural damage this
is instinct and how much of this has
planned I think he would say it's it's
something natural that he sort of just
picked up but he either has an amazing
instinct or he's learned more than he
remembers learning because his technique
is so consistent and it's just nobody in
the game is is matching him now the
other thing he has is his willingness to
do things that would be embarrassing to
other people you know he's willingness
to go outside the box and take the risk
so if he add his gigantic personality
with his willingness to break the edges
on everything you know almost everything
every tweet he does has a little
something wrong with it and when I say
wrong I mean perfect you know wrong in
exactly the right way you know even even
his famous you know stormy Daniels
horseface tweet so he will consciously
pick something that will make you obsess
on it because it's the error that makes
you focus you know
your brain is designed to flush out all
the stuff that's normal and doesn't
matter you know when I when I leave this
room I'm not gonna remember the other
scenery or anything I'll remember just
the key things and he's just great and
making you focus on the key things and
make and making you think about what he
wants you to think about better than
anybody ever I mean one of the questions
that I have is whether this is a bit of
a nun falsifiable thesis the reason I
ask that is because at the end of the
book you have an appendix where you say
here are the things that I think that
President Trump has said that are just
wrong when you talk about
charlottesville you talk about some of
the other things that you think that the
obviously the Access Hollywood tape
which was before he was running but is
not a great thing to say and and how do
you decide prospectively when you see
something the president says is this an
act of communicative genius or is this
an act of complete and pure idiocy
because there's a very thin line
sometimes yes the president says so so
it's the perfect question and it's the
reason back in 2015
I said clearly and often I said this as
often and publicly as I could you won't
be able to tell if I'm guessing luckily
unless I tell you this is a prediction
I'm gonna tell you the tools he's using
as he uses them so you can follow along
and I predict he'll win the presidency
back in 2015
because of the tool set not even because
the policies or anything else and so
exactly to your point if you can't
predict it
what is it right you know it's just
you're describing the past and you can
fit almost any theory to the past
indeed when Hillary Clinton lost I think
how many reasons to CNN prints the next
day you know just dozens of reasons well
here's the reason here's the reason she
did this wrong so you can fit any theory
to the past and that's why I was so
obsessed about saying I'm predicting
this okay so what does you what do you
predict that in for 2020 since you
already have you have one data point
that is in your favor exorcism in one
election it's been one data point in
your favor what do you think happens is
well let me point out that I also
predicted the North Korea situation a
year before it happened so I was
predicting for the same reason that
Trump's skill set would be uniquely
perfectly suited for the North Korea
situation and so far it's looking like
it's moving in the right direction we
don't know but everything looks positive
my back to 21 yes I mean that one is I
think we're gonna need
more data before I hand you that one
okay just to be fair just because I mean
we don't know like the it's there's
there's not enough information yet
whether this is just a pushing off play
by the North Koreans or whether they're
secretly developing anything or whether
anything has really happened but I mean
they look their own nuclear mountains
well but you can see some things that
are really positive for example
apparently they've reduced their
internal propaganda and that would be
the first thing you'd look for to see if
it's real because they don't want to
they don't want to reverse course on
their internal propaganda and then have
to reverse it again I mean why would
they do that they would just keep it the
way it was may so those are all positive
signs and it there does seem to be that
the president has a personal
relationship and that might be the key
it seems to me that what the way he
played it was you know the opposite of
how had been played before he started
with you know the boss Kim jong-un and
said let's you know let's talk let's
show you some respect let's make you a
player who's you know it belongs on the
stage and then we can negotiate as sorta
peers you know not really it can't be a
peer with the United States but at least
in terms of respect and that was
probably a key thing it probably also
allowed Kim jong-un to say I can work
with this guy and if I give up some
things I won't necessarily be vaporized
so there was something about Trump's
willingness to talk to anybody which
he's often criticized for that it's like
a superpower he can talk to anybody you
can make a deal with anybody if it's in
the best interest of the country that is
a wildly powerful thing do you think
there been cases where you've over
applied your thesis or maybe have you do
you have a perfect record in other words
since 2015 I've never been wrong yes so
there there are there are times for
example trying to guess the vice
president pick that was an overreach
because really to make that pick you had
to have to know about personal chemistry
you'd have to know the biographies you'd
have to know the secret of vetting
information you can't really pick a vice
president from this distance but had I
known that Mike Pence was even on the
shortlist he's the perfect choice for a
vice president because he's sort of the
the bad version of the president the
boring versions you know if you started
with Trump and you removed
everything interesting about him it
would be Mike Pence and I like Mike
Pence right there's nothing because Mike
Pence well all of us all the fun the
interest the thing that makes you you
know look at the president and you can't
look away even if you hate him or love
them all that stuff is you know sort of
missing in Mike Pence who is a top-rate
politician he just doesn't have the
stuff then so back to my question about
2020 you're looking forward a couple of
years here and obviously the pollsters
are I would say 50/50 on where President
Trump is at this point because he's
riding kind of where he was expected to
be below 50% maybe a little bit above
where his expect to be he's 46 47 in
some of the polls do you look at any of
the Democrats who are out there and say
this one is a particularly president
Trump nope
at this point I don't see anybody who
would be a serious threat Kamala Harris
it's close you know we'd have to see I'd
have to see her in action a little bit
more on a sort of a running for
presidential you're running for
president kind of basis but I think
she's got the tools and that doesn't
mean she'll come close if if things keep
going the way they're going well take
for the fact just consider the fact that
there was a recent poll that said health
care is the number one issue it's the
number one issue because he's doing so
well on other big issues right Isis is
off the off the headlines North Korea's
looking good economy looking good you
know so health care just rose up he
needs to do something about that and you
know this is my left-leaning part of me
here now I think there's probably a
there I think there's a way to adjust
health care the Bill Gates way Bill
Gates recently came out with a set of
ideas for dealing with climate change
you don't have to believe the climate
change is man-made or anything else
about it but his idea was to create a
portfolio of startups and innovative
companies and shine attention on them
and say if these if these companies do
what they're supposed to do is really
going to make a difference to the
climate you could do the same thing or
rip that let's call the Republican
system for lowering health care costs
you could have what I call the
president's portfolio just a spotlight
not any government money but just saying
these
companies are working on all the parts
of healthcare if they succeed would
dramatically lower costs and that's
that's the whole game right you're not
gonna get to universal health care in
this country without dramatically
finding a way to lower the cost okay so
the regulations could be just one second
I want to talk about kind of the 40 mega
mega underwater upside-down Hungry
Hungry Hippos of it all one of the
things I've been spotted on particularly
or Twitter following is you'll tweet
something out saying that the president
has really thought something through and
done something brilliant and everybody
jumps on it with both feet who's in sort
of the president Trump and Club it
because and that this is why you become
sort of the poster boy for the the pro
Trump movement even though you call
yourself a supporter of the president
the same way you've supported every
other president do you think that people
are sort of straw Manning your argument
a little bit online on Twitter because
that's that virtually everyone I see
it's it's sort of like the bill
Mitchell's of the world tweeting you out
and going well this is what I've always
been saying everything the man does is
just pure genius so some of it is
certainly over interpreting things so a
common thing that happens now maybe
every day is I'll get at least one tweet
from somebody saying here it is again
the thing you predicted it came true and
I'll look at it nothing no I talked
about it I don't really predict that
quite that way but you know people are
starting to you know I guess
confirmation bias is just gihan if they
think I've been accurate before they
just think it's it's continuing to
happen but yes there's absolutely a
certainty that some some number of
things I've said oh this is good
technique and it's going to work the
some of them I've misdiagnosed but I
wouldn't know which ones yeah so I guess
the question about you know president
Trump sort of skill set in doing all
this is if he's really obvious question
is if he's such a great communicator
he lost the popular vote by 2.5 million
he won in three states by a combined
total of 80,000 votes the number of
basically a lot of the same folks who
say that president Trump swept the
country did unbelievably well in
consolidating a movement and I was there
the same people who make fun of Hillary
Clinton saying well if you visited
Michigan or Wisconsin once you would
have won but assumes that if she'd done
that she would have won which is to
suggest that she you know
actually blew it more than he wanted but
in this book you really make the
contention that he wanted she didn't
blow it um if that's if he's such a
great communicator why is he stuck at 42
43% why did he win 47% in the in the
popular vote as opposed to being the
sort of over but we've seen great
communicators in the past who've been a
lot more popular it's like the economy
depends how you measure things if you
were to measure Trump on dollars spent
per vote best ever I don't know if
that's true but it's probably tension
it's close that's probably best ever
certainly a modern history if you were
to look at where he started his
popularity within let's say the
Republican Party on day one 5% 10% it's
now 90 so it's nine times bigger than it
was when he started two years somewhere
that's being president but yes well yes
and winning the nomination like it I
mean you get bastard a person there's
big success makes you pop there sure so
if you were to look at that I would say
he's probably influenced more people to
turn from not liking him to like him
then maybe anybody in that in that frame
of time you know maybe Obama is he was
sort of a phenomenon maybe Bill Clinton
but it's a rare air that you can turn
that many people in that length of time
and now he's going for the hardcore
alright we don't know if he'll ever make
a dent in the the Democrats you know the
real haters but you're starting to see
people say you know I didn't like him
but sure like the economy I didn't like
him but we sure seemed safer from North
Korea you know I don't like those judges
necessarily but they're qualified you
know so you're seeing that kind of talk
so some of the theories that you know
you've heard I'm I'll admit I'm a
proponent of the theory that what you
know the gal you brought some dance is
not necessarily the one that you leave
the party with if you're the president
meaning that what got you to be
president is not necessarily what keeps
you being president the people expect a
different thing in the office than they
expected getting to the office right and
if the skillset may not be directly
applicable in terms of communication
strategy so I've suggested that you know
some of his tweets outweighed the
benefits when it comes to or or when he
goes in front of a rally and he and he
makes a reference to a congressman body
slamming someone in the middle of
arguing jobs not mob
this sort of stuff hurts him that and
his fans
I've also argued his most ardent fans
they don't care nearly as much about
policy as about those tweets like the
stuff that they like the most is the
effect the effect is what is attractive
to them not the policy he can dub him
the policy on side of the roads
recorders at the time you actually make
this argument a little bit in terms of
in moderating its policy but they stick
with the effects do you think there's a
point here where he actually does have
to change how he communicates in order
to reach that middle core because his
base is there but every time he says
horseface isn't winning anyone who are
in the middle by going her space about
somebody he shtup well the the the fun
part about this is if you would just go
back in time and remember how we felt
about these tweets just two years ago
whether you loved him or hated him how
did you feel about these tweets your
hair caught on fire Mike you know it was
like uh yeah if you loved him you'd like
don't do that don't do that and if he
hated him it was like ah look what
you've done and now and now he he tweets
horseface about a porn star that he was
you know allegedly got with and the
entire world went horseface I can see it
you know I you would have to agree you
would have to agree that the level of
hair on fire went to maybe a slight you
know tingling on the scalp and and he
has the ability to just make us get used
to it well he definitely inured us I
mean there's no question after after
this many levels of acid on the skin
we've developed a certain a certain
thickness of skin but I do wonder do you
think that but below against a more
complete answer than that that I think
there's a portfolio effect here there's
a diversification effect he throws out a
lot of stuff if you were to go back and
say alright during the campaign these 10
tweets would you have done these 10
tweets mr. expert political person
whoever you're talking to and the expert
was saying no I would I would not have
done 9 of these these are all mistakes
but probably now that we have the
benefit of watching him win probably two
or three were a problem and the seven
just fired up the bay's made it more
interesting collected energy he took
took tension away from his his rivals
but which of the
three could you have picked them in
advance it's hard so I think that we
have to be a little bit humble about
whether we can look at his tweets that
got us here and we didn't recognize
which we're good or bad then there
suddenly we've developed this ability
that no now we can tell now he's
president now I could tell that's a bad
tweet that one will hurt him now there's
something that even I say the same thing
I go in the example you gave you know
talking about physical confrontation in
any way is probably just a bad idea but
I didn't become president and I'm not
sure I would have had the talent to do
it so I I'm I always keep that a little
bit of doubt that maybe just talking
tough maybe being the toughest guy in
the room has some benefits that are not
immediately obvious and I think it might
translate to a lot of different fields
that he's just the toughest one and we
feel that we always feel his toughness
it just comes out in every way how solid
do you feel in the theory meaning is
this theory good until it isn't
so if he loses in 2020 if the bottom
falls out on him and it turns out that
he has that it seems to me that the
American public could have two reactions
to this one is exactly what you say
which is weird
the sound has been turned to 11 and so
our ears have adjusted now to the sound
and now we can't even hear it it's just
white noise in the background at this
point the other possibility is that it's
like I am with my two kids under five
that I love them they run around their
extraordinary loud and at 7:30 and I say
you need to go to bed now because if you
don't I'm gonna go start drinking and is
it possible that the American people
just there's a sort of feeling of return
to normalcy that kicks in in the same
way that there was wrongly with Jimmy
Carter after the after the Nixon forty
years or with warren g harding after the
wilson years that there's sort of a
backlash to all of this or is this just
the new world we live in
i think there's an addiction thing going
on on the people who love Trump that
that and I would say that I'm one of
them in the sense that you know if a
good tweet comes out that I know is
gonna make people angry that's a good
day for me
I actually I can feel it like physically
I can feel the joy and I and I know that
you know 60 million people are giggling
and it almost precisely almost precisely
the same time all over the the country
they're looking at their phones and
they're like
and you get that little jolt right of
whatever chemical the thing that is so I
think the haters will hate the lovers
will love and I think it's gonna be just
like that in 2020 how much of his
success do you think is a result of his
communication skill and how much do you
think is as a result of the Democrats
really sucking at what they do
meaning that he's the beneficiary of
every time he says something that seems
off-the-wall they then proceed to
interpret it as the worst thing since
Hitler and it doesn't matter what it is
every single thing horse neighs it's the
worst thing since Hitler in June Forte
the worst thing since since Hitler every
single thing is the worst thing since
Hitler and so we begin to tune that out
too and so we actually end up not only
tuning out his myriad silliness says but
we end up tuning out their response was
actually in some ways more important
because he strolled them into
undermining their own credibility and
there are critiques of him yeah they've
gone as far as you can go and still be
reasonable but it didn't get it done so
now they're another deciding well we
should be maybe bad people like he was
in in their opinion so we'll just copy
the part that we understand which is the
mean part of the bully part and they're
missing the technique so they're picking
up all the stuff that you wouldn't want
to imitate because they don't get the
technique that they should imitate so
what do you think is I asked you this
before but what do you think if you had
to pick you talk about what 12
techniques here 11 techniques I'm if you
had to pick like the two or three that
are the most effective that he uses on a
routine basis what would those be
you mentioned visual but what were some
of the others well fear so fear as
always you're Goodwin and the Democrats
used that well during the during the
campaign so Hillary made this fear
proposal that Trump was dark everything
he did was dark his proposals were dark
his policies were dark and it may be you
think that there really was you know
concentration camp and in the future
somewhere so fear is always the best you
want identity identity is a powerful one
if you could say we're Americans we're
on this team you know it's us against
them that's always good pacing and
leading is good you want to match your
public and you want to match them even
harder than they are themselves like you
want to be more of them
then they are themselves and you saw
that with immigration remember you
started out with deport 14 million
people sure what do you think people
people who might vote for me yeah well
that's what you want that's what I want
to deport 14 million people when I saw
that people were saying my god how can
you support this man you just get uses
like a monster he's gonna deport 14
million people
I said no based on what I've seen so far
he's pacing the public he's getting
their trust he's saying I'm more like
you than you are like yourself i I'm
gonna get rid of those fourteen million
people but I also predicted along ahead
of time that once he got elected he
would moderate and that that part was
the first one that went away
you know the killing the families of
terrorists like I I want to I want to
fight terrorism harder than you want to
fight terrorism I know you hate
terrorists watch how hard I hate
terrorists now I'm president well let's
be reasonable right so that's the
leading part so you pace them until they
say you and I are the same person like
we think the same the thoughts coming
out of your your mouth are like just the
ones out of my mouth and then he changes
a little bit then they go oh that's me
talking now and then then if they can
follow so that's probably one of his
strongest techniques this is a very
negative view of the American populace
and how we vote right we that these
techniques they can be used in
persuasion are very useful and there's
no question that you're right I mean and
you talk about all the social science
research with regard to how we actually
think and how much of our
decision-making is instinctive and then
we backtrack and create a rational
process based on the work of Daniel
Kahneman and such what does this say
about the future of democracy that's
something we can educate our own way out
of or are we basically destined to fall
into line behind master communicators no
matter which area of the spectrum they
come from I've actually worried that
Trump might be the last human president
and I and I mean that literally in the
sense that the algorithms and the social
media companies will be able to control
the thoughts and the feelings and the
attitudes and even the policy
preferences of the public to such a
degree that the politicians will just
have to do whatever the public is saying
because it's pretty hard to be a
president and do something that 70
percent of the public doesn't want you
to do that's very unusual
the presidents will be captive to the
public as they are except the public
will not be independently thinking and
they won't be led by the president and
vice versa
I think the algorithms will decide what
the public thinks and then the public
will tell the president what to do and
the presidents can either have to do it
or get a new job so it's possible that
even the because of the complexity of
the algorithms you know it's not
something that one one person sits down
and said are okay here's here's my
little equation well tweak this one I
understand how to change us it's nothing
like that
it's complicated it's a lot of different
inputs in all likelihood there is no
human being any of these companies no
single human who understands how the
algorithm works and that means humans
aren't in charge anymore
it means the algorithm is going to do
what it's going to do and we can maybe
say if you change this variable I put it
and pretty sure that something will
happen in this end but it's not a one
variable situation there are so many
variables it's like sort of like climate
change you know modeling it is you know
insanely hard so I think that the
complexity will mask the fact that the
algorithms will start running the show
with a little bit of correction from
humans so you're suggesting that we may
be a lot less skeptical with social
media than we even ought to be even
those of us on the right who have been
very skeptical of sort of the
left-leaning bias in places like
Facebook and YouTube you can be
skeptical all you like it's too late
yeah there's nothing that can happen
that would stop what I just described
well I mean the only question I have
about that is what what is the agenda of
of an algorithm I mean somebody has to
actually create the parameters for the
algorithms in the first place but they
don't know how it's gonna turn out they
can know that tweaking this is likely to
change this but since there are so many
other things being tweaked they can't
really know what the end result is going
to be so complicated of democracy
basically I mean I'm sure we ever had a
real democracy did we I mean didn't we
just come from a or baby glory in it a
period where money it was the thing you
know the the billionaires are backing
certain candidates and you know the
public doesn't know where the big
money's coming from Trump sort of broke
that model because money wasn't the
thing that got him elected
it was personality and technique
but he's such a unique character that
he's stronger than the algorithm he's
stronger than the money you're not gonna
get another one of those yeah good luck
you could try but that is a powerful
package I mean so this is pretty
dangerous message to a certain extent
for the American people because what do
you expect the American people to do
with this okay they're there they're now
controlled by master communicators by
algorithms beyond their control
what are the what's their daily life
look like how do they shape the system I
mean do you have see any cause for
optimism here at all or basically
surrender to your fear machine masters
for the voters it may not look any
different because before it was sort of
the media companies or maybe shaping the
message and then the voters would think
they made their minds up but really
they're just adopting the message of
their their favorite communication
channel so if you're watching Fox you
think your opinion matches Fox hey how
about that I'm watching Fox with my
opinions are the same as those most for
the most case and the people watching
CNN say my opinions match that but
they're not really making opinions
they're receiving opinions the
difference is that going from we're
probably moving from place where there
are people at the top you know not many
of them deciding what the messages will
be for their side that's sort of what it
is is now but Trump is strong enough
that he can he can kind of you know be
above that process but when there's no
Trump and when the algorithm is stronger
than the people running the messages
it's going to be the algorithm so if the
president has the sort of strength
you're suggesting and let's say you're
advising the president on how to create
a system in the United States that could
help prevent the sort of stuff that
you're talking about do you want do you
want to prevent it and what is the
assumption that it must be prevented I
mean the assumption is that that
attempts to manipulate people's free
will by technological companies run by
an Oleg ARCIC few are probably a bad
thing well we just would use your
suggestion right the troubles broke in
the system we're moving to system is
filling it we're moving from the
oligarchic few to this brief time when
when Trump is stronger than the oligarch
to the point where it won't be the
oligarchy and it won't be Trump to some
day there won't be a Trump at that point
the algorithm will be stronger than the
oligarchs and money won't matter anymore
okay and at that point do you think that
the United States is since we're all
presumably thinking more alike under
this
algorithm that's controlling us does it
sort of restore some sort of American
unity or does it do things just continue
to decay in terms of the polarization of
the culture that's a good question and a
lot of that probably gets to Fox News
and maybe a couple other outlets because
if Fox News suddenly just went out of
business
what would the country look like it
would very quickly start to form around
whatever communication channels were
left so I think as long as Fox is there
and CNN and MSNBC and and the like we're
gonna be two sides for a while but I
think the algorithm will drive us to
1.he so let's talk a little bit about
kind of the Dilbert side of you say you
told me before the show that your time
now is split 6040 between politics and
Dilbert so where did where did the
Dilbert side come from what was the
origin of that side of what you do well
I had a day job I worked in a big
company it was a big bank and one day my
boss called me in and I was a sort of a
identify it as a management you know
potential type of person early on and
but boss called me and said I don't know
how to tell you this but the media has
discovered that we don't have any
diversity in senior management and they
said we won't ever be able to promote
you sure a white male and then I was
told this directly by the way I want to
automate clear I'm not interpreting this
is what my boss a a white woman told me
and she was saying it apologetically
like it's not my decision it's coming
from the top but don't expect to get it
in promotion promotion so I left you
know left as soon as I could
got a job at the phone company got on
the management track and a few years in
my boss called me in his office and he
said I don't know how to tell you this
but the media realized we have no
diversity and senior management and
until further notice and we don't know
how long that's going to last you cannot
be promoted because you're a white male
and that was a point where I thought
maybe I need to work somewhere that
doesn't have a boss maybe maybe the boss
is the problem right now I had you know
very specific problems that were
coincidentally the same but having a
boss is never a good idea so I thought
well let's try some things and one of
the things I tried it wasn't the only
thing
I tried but was cartooning and I
submitted some comics that's the short
version and one syndication company said
yes and the rest was Dilbert history now
how's that comic community treated you
since you came out of the closet as a
trump supporter every once awhile I get
the you know the tweet this is I will
never you know read another Dilbert
comic I'm burning my Dilbert book but
for every I think for every one person
who does that there's still nine who
didn't pay attention to politics before
they're not paying attention to it now
they just like their Dilbert comic and
so you talked a little bit about the
fact that coming out politically in the
area where you live was actually a
dangerous thing so what's been the
response in the area you live because
you obviously live in a very
left-leaning area of California yeah so
in Northern California is where the the
San Jose situation happened during the
the primaries when you know some Trump
supporters got attacked just walking
into their cars literally doing nothing
but walking to their cars and that was
about the time I realized that it's
actually physically dangerous and I was
also getting tons of troll traffic and
who knows how much or paid trolls and
how much or not but a lot of them were
branding me you know Joseph gobbles if
I'm pronouncing it correctly so Hitler's
you know PR person now here's the thing
when they're labeling the president
killer and they're labeling me as just a
supporter explaining his technique as
Joseph Goebbels you're creating the
situation where you're it's approval to
punch me it's approval to hit me because
you wouldn't say go hit a candidate
running for Congress but you would say
go hit you know go kill Hitler and if
the situation were reversed and I
thought it was a real hillier
like a real real hillier and I could
stop him I'd kill him I hope you would
do right so that situation was becoming
real in people's minds they had left
politics and had entered the realm of
yeah I think there's a real Hitler
coming and that might be his little
buddy we'd better get him first so I
stopped appearing in public so I don't I
don't do any public stuff if I could
avoid it I've done a few but
we only if I have to so you've met the
president I mean there are pictures that
came out of it what was that like do
they confirm your views of the president
did it undermine your views of the
President and now that you saw him
behind those closed doors you know what
this great relief was because it was
during the time when everybody was
saying that maybe maybe we need the 25th
amendment maybe he's crazy
you know he's flipping down behind you -
behind doors and I thought to myself
what if I'm wrong about all what if I
meet him privately he's just like it's
just whack job right but it turns out
that he's the most reasonable sane
person in person completely personable
for the entire time I was there he acted
like I was the only person in the room
his social skills are off the chart his
charisma is crazy and he's just you know
in the good way and you know nothing
that would even be slightly worrisome
about you know his mental stays he's
definitely in control it seems to me
that overall your philosophy is a pretty
deterministic view of human nature that
people can be controlled from above by
great communications or by algorithms
you and your own life though have made a
bunch of choices that are you know
pretty individually motivated and look
like you're kind of searching off the
beaten track I mean first of all to
leave business and go into comics is one
and then to go from comics to I'm gonna
analyze this kooky candidate who's in
the middle of the wilderness in 2015 and
point out what he's and now I'm spending
60% of my time analyzing his machination
Zinn politics so you yourself a pretty
individualistic guy are you
deterministic about human nature about
yourself I mean well I don't believe in
a free will but I believe that I have to
act as though I have it you know
apparently I'm programmed to act as if I
have it so that that's as far as I go in
terms of the deterministic part so yeah
it might be that we're we're just a
simulation I happen to buy into the
simulation theory that humans are
perhaps a software simulation created by
a prior civilization whoa okay explain
that one well you know Elon Musk's
that's the same thing a lot a lot of the
smartest when he's smoking polish your
organ or like the rest of that I don't
know I you know I think the rest of the
time - but the but the end thereof
physicists who say this - so it's
actually a legitimate thought and the
for those who haven't heard it before
the idea is that
in our lifetime we will certainly be
able to create software simulations that
look and act and and whenever in
whatever way that's true think that
they're real so that they'll just be a
simulation if we can do it it's more
likely that we're the result of it in
other words for every real real
civilization that can get to the point
it can create a simulation that thinks
it's real it won't make one it's gonna
make more than one you know it might be
a kit for teenagers they can hey you
make a civilization so the odds are that
there are far more simulated realities
than there are original species and
there might be more than one original
species but there will always be far
more simulations and you can tell if you
want so did we just get the weirdest one
is that honestly on that and that sort
of philosophical note is that just a way
I know we've gone far afield here but
it's interesting to me hi is that just a
way of escaping God basically I mean
that's as unfalsifiable as God the idea
of a God that created human beings in a
certain way sounds a lot like what
you're talking about it's just that you
called the God a 400-pound guy who
invented a program in his basement it
would have a lot of overlap right and
maybe you would validate our you know
our feelings that we have that there's
there's something that created us and
you know so maybe there's something to
that but I I think that my basic feeling
about the world is that the human brain
did not evolve to understand reality
because it didn't need to
it needed to you know survive and
procreate that's it that was the whole
thing so you go to the grocery store and
you're you know you're buying some
vegetables and you're standing next to
someone who thinks they reincarnated and
on the other side is someone who thinks
that their prophet flew to heaven on a
winged horse and behind you somebody who
thinks they're their Savior walked on
water now some of those my things might
have also happened at the same time but
we're generally walking around with
people who are in completely different
realities if you look at the reality of
the Trump hater versus the Trump
supporter this is what I call two movies
on one screen we think we're looking at
the same thing but we are really not
interpreting as the same reality and a
base level so when you say you know as a
god is a simulation
my my my I guess the way I reduce that
is if it makes you happy and it helps
you predict what's gonna happen next
what's also that makes you happy then
you've got a good filter on life so the
persuasion approach that I take two
things makes me happy and has done a
pretty good job so far of predicting if
it stops if it stops predicting I'll try
to adopt a new filter so I listened to
the interview they did with Sam Harris
and Sam was quite exercised about the
kind of morality of what President Trump
does and he was saying you know do you
trying to peg you down to the idea that
what President Trump has done
politically is immoral do you actually
think that the the stuff that he does
politically the use of these techniques
the kind of inherent fibbing in what
he's doing sometimes is is there a moral
component to that know if it's
directionally appropriate so if what
he's doing is the best example is the
economy so if he tells 10 lies about the
economy and the fact checkers say yeah
that's not exactly true this isn't the
best job since then it's not the best
GDP since then he may be technically
incorrect but what is his intention his
intention is that he understands the
economy is a psychology machine if you
get the psychology right the machine
works so he takes us to a higher level
of hyperbole higher level of optimism he
says everything's better than it's ever
before what does that cause people to do
it causes people to invest because they
say really it's great it's even greater
than I thought it was it's that great
thanks mr. president I'm going to invest
a little extra and what does that do it
makes it great
so the investing makes the economy work
so he's actually sort of using hyperbole
when that's his word he says he uses it
to try to draw us to positive places if
he says that Isis is the worst thing in
the world and it's going to destroy the
planet that's why we have to do so much
to defeat them well that might be a
little bit of an exaggeration but you
still want to beat Isis and if that's
what it took to get her everybody in the
same page let's say a virtuous direction
even if the fact-checking was not
accomplished to be fair to some of you
know President Trump's critics on this
score you know some of the hyperbole
that he's used at attacking his
opponents for example is is I think
pretty obviously not morally or
directionally appropriate when you
suggest that like well give me an
example okay suggesting the Ted Cruz's
dad killed JFK is probably a pretty good
example but you you had acknowledged
that that was just a throwaway right I
mean in the big scheme that wasn't
anything no but it was it was pilot yes
but it was part of an overall kind of
line of attack on cruise the cruise was
was lying Ted and that his his wife is
ugly there's a fair bit of this right so
let me ask you well if Ted Cruz had been
elected would we have such a good
situation with North Korea um well I
maybe not well right so so yeah that now
ask me counterfactuals I mean that's it
that well ever and everybody who's doing
this obviously believes that they are
going to be the best presidents
otherwise they wouldn't do it but is the
it but is it what's wrong with that but
it doesn't make it immoral well so if
you believe it sort of does that the
morality that you are positing is a goal
only morality it is not a means
including morality I'm saying that the
ends justify the means yeah you are
let me say that right to the camera the
ends always justify the means and people
who argue otherwise are doing what I
call loser things because in every
decision I'll talk to you again in every
decision you weigh the costs and the
benefits right it's only if you're
trying to influence somebody you say hey
all the ends didn't justify the means in
there's some cases that's true but
generally speaking in every decision
you're looking at the costs all of them
and you're looking at the benefits all
of them and some of that cost might be
the you know the moral fiber that comes
you know comes apart a little bit if
you're fibbing right so that's just part
of the cost but you still have to
compare it to the benefits that's not
it's not immoral to to prefer benefits
over costs you know if the benefits are
larger than the cost the problem is that
in asking that it's a second sometimes
your perception of the goals and the
means are misaligned every bad person in
history has said the same thing right
which is that I have certain ends and
those justify the means that I'm using
and since I can argue that the ends are
good the means are therefore justified
and one of the things that we have tried
to argue against is the idea that people
can be used as tools in pursuit of
particular means so the idea of grand
equality between men a surging economy
and and a peaceful coexistence leads to
the extermination of entire populations
or the creation of blue logs I think
there's not a bad person in history who
thought justify to me now they're sort
of not calling you that morality is it's
finally somebody doesn't know me but but
you have to you know there's an analogy
problem here
yeah you can't compare some hyperbole
that gets you better policies too you
know the Holocaust no of course I agree
of course I agree with that but well the
question was one of is the president
using immoral tactics when he does that
and your original statement was that he
was not and then you went to the kind of
all the what maybe you're telling me
past the sale but I'm looking at the
whole I'm saying that if you were to
look at in isolation is fibbing good or
bad I would agree with the Oh fittings
bad you know we don't want to live in a
world where everybody's lying but then
we go to realism all right if you're in
the business context is anybody lying
your job everybody right everybody
everybody's lying from why they were
late to why they didn't get the their
report in on time to the marketing is
mostly lies you know dressed up to be
barely legal sales is mostly lies the
government is mostly lies and so Trump
comes in he goes huh I see everybody
around me is lying about 30% of the time
and it seems to be effective I'll ramp
that up to 70 see what happens it's sort
of the same thing it is but is there a
limiting principle meaning at what point
would you adjudicate that the the ends
did not justify the means
so what could was it interim have done
in 2016 let's say this was the argument
that was actually made very often in
2016 as a binary race it's Hillary
Clinton versus Donald Trump Hillary from
a conservative perspective is an
existential threat to a lot of the
things the Conservatives believe so
President Trump is justified in doing
pretty much anything in the leftist view
up to an including collusion with Russia
which I obviously don't believe I think
it's a bunch of crap but the leftist say
well that's what he was willing to do
Donald Trump jr. was willing to do that
get together with the Russians and all
the rest of it what would you say would
be the limiting principle to the idea
that some threat requires the use of 70%
lying or 100% well I'm not sure you
could ever make one rule that you would
be happy applies to all situations
because every situation is a whole bunch
of variable
you know and no two situations are
exactly alike but for example if he had
said I think I'm gonna have Ted Ted Cruz
executed like I'll have a hit squad just
kill him I would say okay that seems bad
oh good we've gotten there because you
know that that would be a precedent that
would not only if he got into office he
may be convicted so it doesn't even work
on a practical level plus you don't want
to start this standard so the whole
thing falls apart right so there's some
of them are just easy but if you say was
it okay for him to insult somebody or to
suggest something in a political
campaign that wasn't true I'm gonna say
that's sort of standard material okay so
where do you see the country going from
here it's it's it seems like your happy
guy with a very pessimistic view of the
future you know it's a different view of
the future but it's actually more
optimistic than I think I let on okay so
what is it what is that vision of the
future what what's that what's the
opposite what's the happy part about
being controlled by algorithms and
everybody lying to you
well the algorithms won't necessarily do
a bad job compared to human performance
humans are pretty sketchy so I don't
automatically assume that humans will be
you know worse at governing or or the
computers will be worse at governing or
worse at driving cars right I'm looking
forward to the self-driving cars tonight
so but i-i've said that we're entering a
golden age and the way I define the
golden age is a weird time that only
really will happen once in a
civilization when you don't have
resource shortages you have idea
shortages if you take the urban areas
for example I've been working with Bill
Polti on the blight Authority and what
he does is he it's a nonprofit where he
clears out in cities and I'm sorry it
clears out blighted areas in the inner
cities and then we're trying to figure
out what to put there and one of the
things you learn is that fixing the
inner cities is not a money problem like
you would think it would be right it's
like Oh nobody has the money to do this
but there are plenty of people who would
put money into it if you had a good
enough idea so we have an idea shortage
not a resource shortage and I don't know
if the world's ever been there before
and that means that if we use our
thinking or person
or our communication skills right we can
solve just about everything now just
about everything I mean a simple example
is cancer there are a whole bunch of
cancer trials and then there a whole
bunch of cancer doctors but the cancer
doctors even the ones who keep up with
it don't know about all the trials and
the trials are specific to specific
types of cancer so now there's a company
I think it's called drive that makes a
database to pair patients with a
specific test because even the doctor
wouldn't know how to find them there's
nothing been added but information and
it has the potential to be just
revolutionized the area by getting
people to the right the right kind of
treatment so there's just you see
something like that just in all other
realms all other realms of civilization
right now so I do have one final
question before I want to ask you
whether the lessons of President Trump
can be applied to any other politician
can can we can we look forward to
applying those lessons in our own life
and if so how
but if you actually want to hear Scott's
answer you have to be a daily wire
subscriber to subscribe just go over to
daily Wired icon click subscribe give us
your money you can hear the end of our
conversation there well go check out the
book win big lis by Scott Adam Scott
thanks so much for stopping by
fascinating stuff and it's great to see
you thank you
[Music]
eventually row shows Sunday special is
produced by Jonathan hey executive
producer Jeremy borin associate producer
Mathis Glover edited by Alex Singaram
audio is mixed by Dylan case hair and
makeup is by Jess wah Oliveira and title
graphics by Cynthia and gula the Ben
Shapiro shows Sunday special is a daily
wire for word publishing production
copyright for publishing 2018
[Music]